just talk us through the new findings
and in particular
these concerns between the link between
these rare blood clots
and the oxford jab there is still
no data no evidence to support that
there is a
definite link between these blood clots
and the astrazeneca oxide vaccine the
ema that's the european medicines agency
the world health organization
and our own mhra have looked
at the the data they have so
far but nothing to suggest or no
evidence no hard evidence
to suggest that these vaccines were
causing
these very rare blood clots they have
happened
in extremely rare cases in a very small
number of cases
on the continent and that's enough to
prompt governments
to act independently on the continent
the the germans for example they're not
administering the astrozenica oxide
vaccine to anyone
under the age of 60. so they've taken
that decision and that's not the
decision that the
ema has pushed onto its members it says
the vaccine is still safe
and that's certainly what the mhra says
but what has happened
this evening is that oxford university
has said it's
pausing a clinical trial among
children of this vaccine administering
this vaccine
to some people who are taking part in
clinical trials and these clinical
trials
happen all the time we heard from pfizer
just last week
that it was them conducting its own
trials in children
and we even spoke to some children who
were taking part in those trials now
let me read to you what oxford has said
about
this vaccine it says whilst there are
still no safety concerns
in the pediatric clinical trial we await
additional information from the mhra on
its review
of rare cases of thrombosis that have
been reported in adults that means that
the mhra is still looking at the
evidence it's still
carrying out its review into the safety
of this vaccine
and then this statement goes on to say
before giving any further vaccinations
in the trial and that's really important
children aren't routinely vaccinated for
covid19 this is
a small trial that's taking place and
that's what has been paused parents and
children
should continue to attend all scheduled
visits and can contact
the trial sites if they have concerns
but what this will do sophie
is this will put another question mark
another
flag against the vaccine because now
people will look at it and say well if
oxford are pausing clinical trials in
young children
does that mean it's not safe no it
doesn't mean that what it means is
they are waiting for the mhra to look at
the evidence and to guide them
further for now everyone including the
mhra
the world health organization the ema
and anyone connected with the vaccine
and its safety
says it is safe to use but of course
there have been some deaths which
prompted some governments to to stop
giving that vaccine
to younger people